Bolivia,
Chile,
all the fifty cents and Kanye west of
Latin America.
Now it is true,
they share a border,
but other than that they couldn't be
more different.
So Olivia is one of the poorest
countries on the whole continents.
While Chile is among the wealthiest
Bolivia is a paragon of these so called
indigenous socialism.
While Chile is known as the mod or of
Neo liberalism,
and as if this was not enough,
the two countries are involved in
seemingly never ending territorial
disputes with each other nonetheless.
Now that is one thing that these two
countries have in common.
Yes.
If you are,
we are talking about a white gold.
God Damn.
No,
no,
no.
That type of white gold.
I'm talking here about lithium.
Lithium is used for the manufacturing of
batteries that power your cell phone,
your laptop,
and those electric cars.
This eventually you might flood our
roads and highways,
the coat,
the new oil.
If the latest metal on the periodic
table,
it's value has gone up tenfold in the
last two decades alone and it's demand
won't stop growing between 60 and 80
percent of the world's known reserves
are in an area called the lithium
triangle.
This is an area that covers parts of
Argentina,
Bolivia,
and Chile.
In these countries,
lithium is abundant and easy to extract.
In other words,
this part of the planet might soon
become a new Saudi Arabia
forum that it's found in,
is found in these dried up salt lake's
solars,
so Brian's,
which is very different than getting
lithium out of hard rock.
It's a much cheaper,
much more effective among those three
countries.
Bolivia is the luckiest one.
The so called salons.
A Uni holds two or three times more
lithium reserves than the mines in
Argentina or in Chile.
Now,
on the other hand,
the Chili already has a world class
mining industry.
However,
despite these reserves,
Bolivia is exporting less lithium than
the other two countries,
and shelley might actually soon be out
of this new white gold rush.
In fact,
Argentina is the nation that is getting
the most attention from international
investors,
so today's question has to be what's
going on in Bolivia?
Why is no one exploiting?
Then lithium resources and why is Chili
following six today?
We're going to answer all of those
questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look at the history
new Potosi.
Now,
if you've been subscribed to visual
policy for a while,
you already know that having natural
resources doesn't mean that you are
rich,
but if he is an excellent example of
yes,
the country has all the natural wealth,
you can imagine lithium Silva natural
gas.
Nevertheless,
it is still one of the poorest countries
in all of South America.
The silver mines of Potosi,
where the state of war for the Spanish
crown during the 16th and 17th centuries
backed
Spaniard still say
this is worth a potosi,
meaning that something is too expensive,
but the native Bolivians didn't reap the
benefits of that silver wealth and
millions died under the stream working
conditions in the mines.
This is why it's pretty understandable
that the governments of Evo Morales says
is so reluctant to allow foreign
companies to get into the country and
extract the liquid.
Yeah,
let's Let.
Let's be honest,
the real business here is not the raw
materials,
Bart in the industry that comes
afterwards for a better understanding of
this.
Why don't we make this video a metric
ton of lithium costs around $9,000 on
the international market,
but if we take that raw lithium,
then we turn it into batteries for
mobile phones,
we can turn that lithium into a value of
somewhere between one point five and
$5,000,000.
Of course,
this is just a rough estimate of value
and there are lots of things that should
be considered here,
but it can help to look into comparison.
Indeed it can help explain it and use
this.
Plus he take Abel Morales Morales opened
in 2013 the first plant of lithium
carbonate and in February 2014 limit the
first manufacturing facility for lithium
ion batteries,
but that is not all in Bolivia.
Lithium is nationalized.
This means that if you are a private
mining company and you want to work on
Canadian soil,
you must partner with the government and
start a new company which will be owned
partly by the governments.
This new company can get paid for their
service and building the mind,
setting up the machinery and extracting
the lithium.
The lithium,
they extract well that belongs to the
government.
They have no rights to it.
What do you wondering?
Why does Bolivia need foreign companies
to exploit that wealth?
They simply do it themselves.
Well,
the short answer is no.
Modern Day mining,
it has nothing to do with the image you
probably have in your mind's going with
a hardhat on they pick axe.
Today.
Mining requires high ends machinery and
world class engineers.
As you can imagine,
these things are scarce in a country is
poor,
has been,
yeah.
Create a competitive mining industry in
that country without outside help.
You would need decades.
This is why it is so important to
utilize companies who have the
technology,
the tools,
and the staff to do the job.
And this is why even Moralez himself
friendly to multinationals have said
that it's time to get out there and find
investors,
elemental getting used.
We have a big lithium industry,
Bolivia.
We'll set the lithium price for the
whole world.
I want you to say to you governments and
private companies now you can join us.
So.
Alright,
so what exactly is the problem here?
Well,
as we said before,
Bolivian lithium is owned by the state.
This means that companies that might
invest in the country can only get to
profit by partnering with the
governments and from that profit,
a famous pay,
a special mining tax that goes up to 37
point five percent,
which is by far the largest in the
region.
And if all of this wasn't enough,
well,
according to the world's bank,
Bolivia ranks among the 50 countries
where it is hardest to do business,
they rank at about the same level as
Sierra Leone.
So now let's say that you're someone who
wants to invest in lithium.
Do you fancy investing in Bolivia or
maybe you might prefer one of those
other countries.
You know,
maybe this explains why the moments
Bolivia Wallace is the country with the
biggest lithium resources.
It is also the country that is
exploiting them.
The least.
If you pay attention to the chart,
you will see that today,
the leader of the lithium race is
awesome,
surprising because the resources of this
country off four times smaller than
those of Bolivia Fonts,
Australian salaries are six times higher
than Bolivian ones.
So as you can see,
this is not a matter of low pay jobs on
natural wealth,
but simply good and bad economic
policies.
But hold on just a minute because this
is not the only problem.
Don't forget that Evo Morales dream is
for Bolivia to become a manufacturing
leader in the lithium battery industry.
But I mean how exactly is he going to
achieve this without foreign companies
setting up insight.
Alright,
so yeah,
the government can set up its own
factory and that's all great and
everything,
but technology patents and the skills
needed that held by companies like
Panasonic.
Samsung will tesla without these
Bolivia,
would need decades of research in order
to be competitive on the international
markets.
Alright,
so a while ago we mentioned Chili.
Now let's go over and have a look at
what's happening over there.
Chalet follows in the steps of Bolivia.
For years,
Jenny has been known as something of a
free market,
Disneyland or precisely they're mining
industry was one of the freest in the
entire world.
We're talking about the country,
whether your comedy relies heavily on
copper mining.
This is why you have,
again 1981 Pinochet's dictatorship past
these so called mining law.
This allowed private businesses to own
100 percent.
As you can imagine,
this little kickstarted foreign
investments in the country.
Suddenly lots of companies like the
Australian Bhp Billiton or the Swiss
xstrata came to Chile.
Yeah,
listen,
I know what you're thinking.
All these multinational companies while
they looted to the country and left it
in poverty,
rice,
right?
Well actually that's
really wrong.
Of course these Canadian,
Swiss and Australian companies came to
extract the cop,
right.
Also helped to finance lots of brand new
companies which employ Chilean workers
and we're headquartered in Santiago,
companies like Manera Escondida or
Antofagasta mining.
In fact,
thanks to this wave of investors,
Chili now has any world class mining
industry,
actually many of the engineers that are
now needed in Bolivia,
they live in the best neighborhoods of
Santiago and this means that one has
been in a great position to lead this
point.
Gold Rush.
Nonetheless,
in 2016 Chilean presidents,
Michelle Backlash declared that the
lithium was a different animal
from the strategic condition of lithium,
which is property of all Chilean people
and we'll keep it state as
nonconcessional material.
In other words,
the governments of Chiney is following
suit with Bolivia barter.
They do have an important difference in
this case.
The country already has the technology
and the staff to exploit its mineral
wealth in an efficient way.
Of course,
many of these companies who were willing
to invest in the country have lost all
interest,
but surely has its own companies,
so it's not so big a deal besides until
2014.
The other countries have this lithium
triangle in Argentina,
in Bolivia,
well way worse places for investments,
so in this case is sort of like in the
land of the blind,
the one eyed passing is king.
Well,
they entail now Argentina has been the
big surprise here while Chile and
Bolivia have nationalized the lithium
and have tried badly to scare away
foreign companies.
Argentina with Mauricio Macri as its
president is doing something rather
different and the now getting all the
attention from international
investors.
We're actually going to talk about that
in upcoming weeks in a sort of second
part to this video.
So if you don't want to miss that,
please do be sure to subscribe to this
channel.
In the meantime,
we've got a question for you.
Do you think that Bolivia,
Chile can reap the benefits of their
lithium with these kinds of policies or
maybe Argentina will somehow overshadow
them?
You can leave me in the comment section
below and just before we go today,
I've got a really important question and
sort of a request from you.
You might've noticed that we'd rather
like using rock music in our videos and
we'd love to hear from anyone who has a
bands and things that Ben Music could be
a good fit for us.
We'll of course,
give you full credit in the video.
If we do use your music.
If you're interested in did not,
please drop us an email.
You can do that at Info App,
visual politic.net.
Also,
please don't forget to visit our friends
at the reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that are not mine,
and if you liked this video,
give it a thumbs up and as always,
see you next [inaudible].